the unlv school of medicine is
officially an accredited institution
this means it is meeting or exceeding
national standards
katie houston joins us live in the
newsroom tonight to break down how this
title could help stop the shortage of
doctors in our state
kate yes sasha nevada has one of the
lowest rates of doctors per capita
today i spoke to the dean of the school
of medicine he says having this
accredited medical school in southern
nevada will not only help retain doctors
but could help expand the types of
procedures that are offered to our
community
this is great news for unlv and it's
great news for our community
dr mark khan the dean of the unlv school
of medicine
says the accreditation process was years
in the making and is a crucial step in
addressing the shortage of medical
workers in nevada
i think that we're really victims of our
large
influx of population which is a good
thing but the health care industry never
quite
caught up this shortage also has to do
with the lack of residency positions
which is an essential step to becoming a
doctor
there are only 400 residency positions
in nevada compared to the 19 thousand
positions in new york
this means many medical students are
going out of state for their training
and not coming back we really want our
students whether they do their
residencies in state or not we'd like
them to
but we recognize that there's really not
enough positions in the state
we want them to come back and practice
here so having a fully accredited
medical school
is really important to attain that goal
by expanding residency programs it will
allow students to focus on more
specialties such as urology pediatrics
and ophthalmology in doing so families
in southern nevada will receive even
more
options for care we don't do liver
transplants in the state we don't do
bone marrow transplants in the state
these are no longer experimental
protocols these are really standard of
care
and it's my hope and my plan that over
time we're going to develop each and
every one of these
because after all this is what our
population deserves
unlv now joins around 150 other
accredited medical schools in the nation
including university of nevada reno back
to you sasha